[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
JASON KU: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to the last
lecture of 6.006.
Last lecture, we talked
about summing up this class
and talking about future
courses in the department that
use this material.
Just as a pointer to
some of those classes,
I have a little slide
here I didn't get to
at the last lecture,
talking about what
I was talking about at the
end of the last lecture
about different models--
different specialized classes
on different aspects of 006
material--
for example, more graph
stuff, different models
of computation,
randomness, complexity.
All of these things have
their own specialized classes
in the department, as well
as a lot of applications
for this material in subjects
like biology, cryptography,
and in particular, for
your instructors, the realm
of graphics and geometry.
All of your
instructors this term
happened to be geometers
and be interested
in geometry-related problems.
Me in particular, I didn't
start out in computer science.
I started out in
mechanical engineering.
And the thing that was my
passion coming into MIT
was origami.
Here's a couple of
pieces that I designed--
origami pieces, one square
sheet of paper without cutting.
Here's a lobster, and here's
a copyrighted dinosaur
from a particular movie of
the year that I designed it.
When I was young,
in high school,
I started designing
my own origami models.
And what I didn't realize
was, the procedures
that I went about
designing these models
was actually algorithms.
And I just didn't have
the mathematical language
to understand exactly
what I was doing,
but I could gain some
intuition as an origami artist
and design these
things by using some
of those algorithmic techniques.
It wasn't until grad school,
as a mechanical engineer,
that I started talking with
our other instructor here,
Professor Demaine, about using
algorithms and computer science
to design not just
origami, which we both do,
but also folded structures
that can be used for mechanical
applications like space flight,
deployable bridges in times
when you can't--
you need a temporary bridge or
shelter or something like that.
Deployable structures
where you might
need to make folded structures--
transformable structures that
can have different applications
for different purposes--
need to reconfigure.
The dream being that, we
have these powerful devices
in our pockets right
now-- cell phones--
which are really powerful
because we can reconfigure
the bits in them
to make software
of all different kinds, right?
There's an exponential
number of different programs
that we can write.
And that's part of
why you're here,
is to write the next best one.
Right?
So that's how to make
kind of a universal device
at the electronic level.
What if we could do that
from a material standpoint?
What if I could reprogram the
matter in my phone so that,
not only could I reprogram
the app that's on your phone,
but instead of having, say, the
iPhone 10 or whatever that you
have, and you want to
go by the iPhone 11,
instead, you download a software
app that then reconfigures
the matter in your phone--
it folds or reconfigures into
the next generation iPhone.
You don't have to throw
away that old one.
You can essentially
recycle the material
that you have to potentially
save material, save
cost, and be better for the
environment, potentially.
So I started moving
into computer science
because I found that it
was a really good way
to model the world
and solve some really
interesting problems about
folding that I really enjoyed.
The three of us today
are going to spend
some time talking a
little bit about how
we can use algorithms--
6.006 material and beyond--
in our own research.
And we're going to start
off with Professor Demaine,
and then Professor Solomon.
ERIK DEMAINE: Thanks.
So let me just jump in here
to computational origami
and geometric
folding algorithms,
sort of a broader umbrella for
folding-related things, which
is encapsulated by
this class, 6.849,
which is happening next fall.
So you should all take it.
006 should be a
reasonable background.
And in general, we're interested
in two kinds of problems.
One-- the big one
is origami design,
or in general,
folding design, where
you have some specifications of
what you would like to build.
In this case I wanted to
make a logo for 6.849.
And I imagined extruding that
text into third dimension.
And then I wanted an
algorithm to tell me
how to fold that structure.
And so there is an
algorithm, which
I'll talk about
in a moment, that
gives you a crease pattern.
And then, currently,
you fold it by hand.
The dream is, we'll eventually
have folding machines that
do it all for us.
And so that's the
origami design,
where you go from
the target shape
back to the crease pattern.
The reverse direction
is sort of foldability.
If I gave you a structure like
this and I wanted to know,
does it fold?
That's the problem
we call foldability--
in general, class of problems.
And sadly, most of those
problems are NP-hard.
Jason and I proved
that foldability
is hard for a general-- given
a crease pattern like that,
telling you whether
folds into anything,
it turns out to be NP-hard.
So that's bad news.
So we focus a lot on
the design problem,
because that actually
tends to be easier.
We can solve it with algorithms
like that one you're seeing.
A long time ago, we proved
that you can fold everything.
If I give you a
square piece of paper
and you take any polygon
you want to make--
or maybe the paper's white on
one side, black on the other,
you want to fold some two-color
pattern, like a zebra,
or in general, some
three-dimensional surface,
like these guys, there
is a way to fold it
from a large enough
square of paper.
And it's actually really easy
to prove that with an algorithm.
I have the sketch of
the two pages of proof
that we go over in
6.849, but I'll just
hand-wave a little bit.
If you take a piece of
paper, like my lecture notes
here, the first thing
you do is fold it down
into a very long, narrow strip--
much longer and
narrower than this one--
wasting most of the material.
And then you take your strip,
and you just figure out
how to turn it in
some general way,
and then you just sort
of zigzag back and forth
along the surface.
So it's very cool in that you
can prove with an algorithm,
and in a very short
amount of time,
to someone you can
actually fold everything.
Of course, it's a
terrible folding,
because in the
very first step, we
throw away all but
epsilon of the material.
But it's a starting point.
That was back in the '90s--
late '90s-- one of
the first results
in computational origami.
And in modern times, we
look for better algorithms
that are more efficient, that
try to minimize the scale
factor from, how big
of a piece of paper
do I start from to, how
big of a model do I get?
And one of the cool
ways these days, which
was invented by
Tomohiro Tachi and then
analyzed by the two of us--
it's called Origamizer.
It's free software.
You take a 3D
model and you can--
it makes it into a pattern
that you fold from a square.
In this case, it uses 22% of
the area, which is pretty good--
similar to these guys
in terms of efficiency.
But very, very different
kind of folding
than what you would get from
more traditional origami
design, which uses
different algorithms, which
I'm not going to talk about.
But you should take the class.
Jason gives a
lecture in the class,
so you can learn from him.
But the vision is, we can take
any sheet of material that
can hold a crease, like
this sheet of steel
that Tomohiro is folding.
It was cut by a big
laser cutter at MIT.
And this is him in
this Data Center
several years ago, folding
it into a steel bunny.
And so this is a totally new
way to manufacture 3D objects.
And you can make particularly
interesting objects
that either collapse flat for
transportation or transform,
like Jason was talking about.
But I'm just giving
you a flavor.
I think the first paper we wrote
together was on maze folding.
So this is an example
of folding a maze
from a rectangle of paper.
And you can all try this out.
You just google for
our Maze Folder.
You can generate a random maze.
And this 3D structure
can be folded
from this crease pattern.
That's a really hard one, so
maybe try something smaller.
You can also write your favorite
message and fold this maze--
extruded graph-- from
this crease pattern.
Might want to start
with something smaller,
but that's the general idea.
And it's actually quite easy
to prove this algorithmically,
if you have a really
good origamist
like Jason on your team.
What you do is design how
to fold each type of vertex.
This is just a graph on a grid.
There are some constant
number of different ways
that each vertex could look.
It could be degree 4.
It could be degree 3, as
a T. It could be degree
2, either a turn or a straight.
And you design little gadgets,
little crease patterns,
that fold into each of
those little structures.
And if you can do it in a
way that these boundaries are
compatible, then to
fold the whole thing,
you just sort of gluon
together those crease patterns.
And that's how that
software works.
This was particularly
interesting,
because you can fold an
arbitrarily complicated graph--
arbitrarily complicated
maze, n by n,
with a constant scale factor.
As long as the
height that you're
extruding that maze
is constant, then
this is one family of shapes we
know how to fold really well.
In general, we're
trying to understand,
what makes this lobster
a nice shape in that it
can be represented with a
not-too-large piece of paper.
And we don't have general
answers to that problem.
I think that was a whirlwind
tour of computational origami.
I also play a lot in
algorithmic sculpture.
One of the leading edges
in origami and origami math
is understanding how
curved creases work.
And one of our
favorite models is
this one, where you fold
concentric circles alternating
mountain and valley,
cut a circular hole out,
and it folds into this
kind of Pringle shape
as a nice physics
equilibrium thing.
And then you can turn it into
fun sculptures like this.
These are done with my dad,
Martin Demaine, who's also here
at MIT, or this guy.
This paper has been
printed with a pattern
according to getting
burned by glass.
And then it gets folded and
then put inside glass, also.
Made here at MIT.
We use sculpture to try
to explore and understand
intuitively how
curved creases work,
and then we get better
and better understanding
of the mathematics of even--
we don't even know whether this
surface exists, whether it's
possible to fold in this
way, although getting
close to proving it.
That was sort of in the top
level of this hierarchy.
Computational geometry
is a bigger umbrella,
which is represented by
another class, 6.850,
that's being taught this term.
And then I talked
about geometric folding
within that branch.
Let me briefly tell
you about another world
of geometry-- very different in
terms of model of computation.
Oh, I jumped ahead a little bit.
Rewind.
Let me show you
one more fun demo,
which-- if I find my scissors.
If I take a rectangle of
paper, and I fold it flat
and make one straight cut,
what shapes can I get?
It's called the
folding cut problem.
It's hundreds of years old.
Here, for example, I get a swan.
Here, I get-- one straight cut.
I unfold and get angelfish.
Tough audience today.
I've got to keep going.
You've seen all of these before.
This is this one is a
particularly difficult one
to fold--
to only fold.
And to cut, yeah.
OK.
That works well.
This is the MIT logo.
Ooh, ah.
AUDIENCE: Ooh, aah.
MIT, yeah!
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Go, MIT.
All right.
That's actually
the first problem
I worked on in
computational origami.
It's a lot of fun.
And there's a really interesting
algorithm here, also,
for computing the
crease pattern,
how to fold your piece
of paper to align--
in fact, any graph you
draw on a piece of paper,
you can align all of those
edges and nothing else.
So you cut along the line and
you get exactly what you want.
Cool.
All right.
Now, I want to talk about
something completely different,
which is self-assembly.
A fun thing you can do with
DNA, which we all have.
Just pick out some
cool DNA strands
and design them in a clever
way so they fit together
to form a kind of square
with dangling ends, which
I'll call glues and each
of those dangling ends
can have a very
particular pattern,
and only identical or
complementary patterns
will attach to each other.
And so you can
use this to design
your own self-assembling
system, like biology
does, but engineered, for
example, to build a computer.
This is an example of taking
a bunch of these square tiles
and building a binary counter.
This thing is roughly counting
in binary along the diagonal.
It's a little skewed,
so it's hard to see.
But the general model
is, you have squares--
this is sort of the
computational model--
with four different glues.
And you can build
any square you want,
but you don't have very many of
these different glues, ideally.
And then, if you have two
tiles with complementary glues,
they will want to
match together.
But it depends how strong this
glue is, how much affinity
there is for how long those
DNA dangling ends are,
and also, the temperature
of your system.
If you have really high
temperature, nothing.
Will stick together
low temperature,
things will stick together even
if they're not supposed to.
If you tune your
system really well,
you can design a system so that
maybe these guys-- these glues
are really strong.
And so let's, I don't
know, write "E" here--
Erik.
And so these tiles will
always glue together,
but only when all three of
these are glued together
can this tile--
which has C complement
and F complement.
Then it will, if you set
the temperatures just right,
only because both of
these edges match will
this dial be able to come in.
And that's the basis for
building that binary counter.
This is a very different
model of computation
from what we're used
to in this class,
where you think of instructions,
and they run one at a time.
Here the, model of
computation is geometric.
It's these squares that are
just floating around and gluing
together.
And so your program,
at any moment,
is some conglomerate of squares.
I just wanted to
mention it because it's
a really fun model.
You can prove cool
things in this model,
like how to build any shape
by a sequence of pores
mixing between tiles that
you can execute in parallel.
And so it only
takes log and time
of parallel steps, a linear
number of different mix
operations, to make
an arbitrary shape--
even using a constant number of
different glues, which is cool,
and maybe practical.
You can also use it to
build a replicator, where
you're given an object
like this that you
don't know the shape of--
like, we don't know
whether this exists,
and we can't model it
mathematically very well,
and you stick it in a vat,
and all of these tiles
would attach and
basically build a mold,
and then start photocopying,
in 3D, that mold.
And you can build that with
a system with only two steps,
I believe, and a constant
number of tile types.
And it does all of that, in
this model, in constant time.
In reality, you would
have to feed this machine
and wait for it to print
out all of these things,
and these experiments take
hours, if not days, to run.
But in theory, it's really cool.
And you get some
really fun models
and very general results.
You can also use it to build
a miniaturizer or a magnifier
and other fun stuff.
That was a brief tour of
computational geometry.
I work mostly in four different
areas of algorithms-- geometry,
data structures, graph
algorithms, and what
I call recreational algorithms.
I think I made up that term.
And let's go into
data structures,
which is represented
by this class, 6.851.
All of the classes I mentioned
have online video lectures,
especially for those watching
at home on OpenCourseWare.
Most of these classes are on
OpenCourseWare, and if not,
they're on my webpage.
6.851, Advanced Data Structures,
is an extension of the sorts
of data structures
you've seen here,
in 006 and the ones
you will see in 6.046.
I thought I would
give you a flavor
of one such result,
which is a problem we've
seen in this class done better.
Suppose you want to store
a dynamic ordered set.
This is the set interface.
Dynamic in the sense that
I have insert and delete,
and ordered in the sense that
I want to support find-next
and find-previous.
Exactly which subset
of the set interface
you choose influences what
data structure you've seen.
We've seen, for dynamic sets,
you want to use hashing.
If you don't care
about find-next,
if you just care about
find, then hashing
is great-- constant expected.
You can prove stronger
things about hashing.
And we do in that class.
But if you want
dynamic and ordered,
you cannot do constant
time per operation.
You can prove that,
which is cool.
What data structure have we seen
that solves this problem pretty
well?
Set AVL trees, which
solve everything in log n.
So log n is one competitor.
Yeah.
I'm interested in
the word RAM model,
which is the only model
we've seen in this class.
This happens to work
in a stronger model.
And we can do better than
log n in the following--
it will take me a while
before I get better,
but here's, at least, a
different bound we can get--
log w.
This is via a structure called
van Emde Boas, who is a person.
AVL is two people.
van Emde Boas,
I've actually met.
Log w-- remember,
w is our word size.
So this is a bit of
a weird running time.
It's great if w is log n,
then this is log log n.
And we know w is at least log
n, but it could be bigger.
We don't really have a sense
of how big w could get.
Maybe it's even n.
Maybe it's big-- and
then these are the same.
Maybe it's bigger than n,
and then this is maybe worse.
But for most ws, this is
actually pretty good--
and indeed, optimal.
But it's not strictly
better, in any sense, yet.
On the other hand, there's
another data structure which
runs in log n divided by log w.
This is called fusion trees.
This was invented
around the time
that cold fusion
was in the news,
and so they wanted data
structures to represent.
We can achieve this bound or
we can achieve this bound.
And this bound is
good is if w is large.
This band as good if w is small.
You can always take the min of
the two, whatever is better.
And in particular, the min of
those two things is at most--
I think it's square root
log n over log log n.
If you want to bound
just in terms of n,
then the crossover point
between these two is this place.
And so you're always,
at most, this,
which is quite a bit better
than the log n of AVL.
We've got a square
root and we've
got a slight thing
in the denominator.
Pretty tiny.
But the big thing
is the square root.
And that's kind of cool.
And it turns out, that's
pretty much optimal.
In terms of an n
bound, this is optimal.
The min of these
two, in general,
is roughly optimal
up to log log terms.
For fun, I threw up
the actual formula
for the right-bound,
which is tight
up to constant factors of
matching upper and lower
bounds, which we talk about.
It's min of three things--
four things, including log of
w over a divided by log of log
w over a log of log n over a.
That's the last term
that I just read.
This was messy.
Surprisingly, that
is the right answer
for this very
particular problem--
a very natural problem.
AUDIENCE: What is a?
ERIK DEMAINE: A is the log
of the space you're using.
So it's the address size.
Good question.
If you throw it-- so it depends.
If you have a polynomial space
data structure, then basically,
these are optimal.
And this is generalizing
to beyond that.
Maybe you have a little bit
more than polynomial space.
Cool.
So that's data structures.
I'm going to jump ahead to
graph algorithms, which,
if you want to take this class,
I recommend a time travel
device.
Go back to fall 2011.
It may never get taught again.
But it has video,
so you can watch--
instead of time
traveling, if you
don't want to watch
it live, you can just
watch the recorded version.
It was taught by a bunch
of postdocs that were here,
and a bit myself.
What I like to do with graphs
is the world of planar graphs,
or near-planar graphs.
We've talked a lot
about, this class,
algorithms that work
for arbitrary graphs.
And the algorithms
we've seen in this class
are pretty much the best we
know for a lot of problems
for arbitrary graphs.
But if your graph
has some structure,
like it's a road network
and there aren't too
many overpasses, you can usually
draw these graphs in the plane
without crossings.
That's the meaning of planar.
Maybe not exactly.
Maybe just a few crossings.
There's a generalization of
this, which I won't get into.
But let's just think
about planar graphs.
Planar graphs have
some nice features,
like they always have a
linear number of edges.
They're always sparse.
So you can immediately plug
that into our existing bounds.
But even so, Dijkstra, in such a
graph, would take v log v time.
For planar graphs, you can do
the equivalent of Dijkstra,
meaning, I can compute
single-source shortest paths
with negative edge
weights in linear time.
No log.
Not that impressive,
but remove a log.
More impressive is, we can do
the equivalent of Bellman-Ford,
which is a single-source
shortest paths with arbitrary
edge weights in a planar
graph in some time--
almost linear time.
The log squared v
over log log v. So
there's a couple
of factors here--
but for almost linear
time, whereas Bellman-Ford
would take v squared time.
So this is a huge
improvement over what
we've seen in the class.
These are quite
complicated algorithms,
but they're covered
in that class,
if you're interested in them.
Then the area I work in a lot
is approximation algorithms
for planar graphs.
And let me just give you a fun
flavor using something we know,
which is breadth-first search.
Breath-first search
you can think
of as building sort of rings
around a single root node.
And there's this
general approach--
this was introduced
by Baker in 1994,
we've used for lots
of different problems.
We want to solve some
NP-hard problem on a graph.
So just run breadth-first
search from an arbitrary vertex
and decompose your
graph into these layers.
You could number them--
0, 1, 2, 3.
These are levels.
And let's just, like,
delete some of those layers.
Let's say, let's delete
every fourth layer.
So maybe I delete this one.
I delete all of the
vertices in that layer.
And then I delete all
of the things in layer
8, and layer 12, and so on.
Guessing-- I don't know which
one to start with, but from--
I'll just try them all.
And then I delete every
fourth layer after that.
So I've deleted, on average,
about a quarter of the graph.
And it turns out, for a lot of
problems that you care about,
like choosing where to place
fire stations in this graph
to minimize travel
time for if there's
a fire somewhere in the graph--
this happens, you know?
Fires and graphs.
Then this will only hurt
your solution by, like,
a factor of 1 plus a quarter.
So you will get
a solution that's
within 25% of the optimal,
for a lot of problems.
And that works for any value 4.
So I could do it
for 10, and then I
would get within 10% of
the optimal solution.
OK, but how do I actually
solve the problem once I
delete every fourth layer?
Well, then your graph has
this extra special structure,
which is a constant number
of layers, let's say.
A constant number of
breadth-first search layers.
If you just look
at this portion,
this connected component,
or this connected component
in here, you can--
your graph is
almost like a cycle.
It's like four cycles
stacked up together
with some connections
between them.
And it turns out,
that's something
you can solve with very
fancy dynamic programming,
like the stuff we've
seen in this class, which
focuses on just a single
path or a single cycle.
If you just have a
constant number of cycles,
with more work, you can still do
everything in polynomial time.
This is a very general approach
for getting arbitrarily
good approximation algorithms.
We call these 1 plus epsilon
approximation for any epsilon.
But the larger the epsilon,
the more time you take.
It's something like 2 to the
order 1 over epsilon times
polynomial n.
So as long as
epsilon is constant,
this is polynomial time.
This is called a PTAS.
Anyway, that was
graph algorithms.
Last topic is recreational
algorithms, which is maybe
best encompassed by this class.
6.892 is its latest name.
It changes names
every once in a while.
And I mentioned it in the
hardness complexity lecture,
because this class is all
about hardness proofs,
analyzing fun games and puzzles.
We saw the Tetris
NP-hardness in that lecture.
But you can also prove Super
Mario Brothers is hard,
or Portal is hard, or
Mario Kart is hard,
or The Witness, a modern
video game, is hard.
Or, one of our latest
results is that Recurse--
that game in the top
right-- is undecidable.
There's no algorithm to
play that game perfectly.
And you can even
download the level--
an example of the level
and play it, if you dare.
So that's a lot of--
we have a lot of fun in
that world of hardness
of different games and puzzles.
Where do I want to go next?
OK.
Next topic is balloon twisting.
Totally different.
This is recreational,
but not about hardness.
This is an octahedron
twisted from one balloon.
I made another one on a stick.
Each of these is
made for one balloon.
What graphs can you
make for one balloon?
Well, you should read our paper.
And you can characterize
how many balloons you
need to make each polyhedron.
And some of these problems are
NP-hard, and it's a lot of fun.
Cool.
I think that's the
end of the slides.
The last thing I
wanted to show you
is a problem, a
puzzle/magic trick--
it comes from the puzzle world--
called the picture
hanging problem.
So imagine you have a picture.
You want to hang it on a wall.
So you invested
in some nice rope,
and you hang it on a nail.
If the nail falls out, the
picture falls, and you're sad.
So you invest in two
nails, like I have here,
and maybe you hang your
picture on both those nails.
Now, if one of the
nails falls out,
you still have a
crookedly hung picture.
If the other nail falls
out, OK, it's gone.
I want to hang a
picture on two nails
such that, if I remove either
nail, the picture falls.
So, Jason, pick a
nail, left or right.
Left, we remove.
Make sure this
doesn't fall off--
and, boom, the picture falls.
Same wrapping.
You can check-- you
can rewind the video,
make sure I did
the same wrapping.
JASON KU: And take
out the right.
ERIK DEMAINE: Then
take out the right one.
Good choice.
Then, also, the picture falls.
This is a classic puzzle,
but you can generalize it.
So let me do it for three
nails, which is all I have here.
This nail is sagging
a little bit.
y, x-- y inverse, x inverse.
I think that's right.
So this is one way to hang
a picture on three nails
such that, if I remove any of
the nails, the picture falls.
Justin, 1, 2, or 3?
2.
OK.
Yeah, I want to
get out of the way
and make sure I don't
go over the edge here.
Yeah.
It's a lot easier to
make this one work.
But you can see, boom,
picture falls there.
And of course, imagine
infinite gravity.
And the picture falls.
Ta-da!
You can generalize this
to do essentially any--
what's called a monotone Boolean
function-- on any set of nails.
I mean, you can make
any subset of the nails
cause the picture to fall
and any collection of subsets
of nails to make it fall.
Of course, if you
remove more nails,
it's still going to fall.
That's the monotone sense.
But otherwise, you can
do an arbitrary pattern,
which is fun.
That's actually a
result with Ron Rivest
and a bunch of other people.
I think I'm
approximately on time.
So that was a quick tour.
And there are obviously various
classes here you can take.
6.892, the hardness class, was
just offered last semester,
so it probably won't
be for a while.
But all of these
classes are online.
Watch the videos, feel
free to ask me questions.
And now we have Justin.
I left you space here
for your outline.
You don't have to, but
I'll put your name.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Thank you.
JASON KU: So Justin
is also a geometer.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, we've got
a lot of geometry people in 006
this semester.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Thank you.
OK.
I can't help but share that,
on our instructor chat,
Erik was texting that
he was going to be--
he was somehow nervous
that the applied guy would
have all of the cool
stuff to show off,
and now I feel totally boring.
[LAUGHING] Right.
Yeah.
We have three different geometry
instructors in this class.
In this class, I think we
have many different flavors
of geometry that are
kind of represented
in this room here, from
mechanical engineering,
to theory plus lots
of other cool stuff,
to whatever it is that I do.
I'm a professor, also, in
CSAIL, and lead a group
that studies slightly more
applied geometry problems,
in some sense, and in
CSAIL, we kind of cross
a lot of boundaries-- actually,
closer to the math department
than to the theory group
and computer science,
which I would argue is largely
a historical artifact rather
than anything interesting
about computer science or math.
Continuing in our whirlwind tour
of interesting geometry classes
here at MIT, I have some more
fun things to add to the list.
And we'll introduce some of
the ideas in the next couple
of slides here.
So normally, every
fall, I teach 6.837,
which is the introduction
to computer graphics course.
In fact, my background was
working in an animation studio
for a little bit of time, and
got one movie credit out of it
until they changed the
standards for movie credits,
and then that stopped happening.
But in any event, if you
watch-- what's that movie--
Up, with the old man.
If you hit pause at
just the right moment,
you can find me right above
the list of babies that
were born during production.
But in any event--
although computer
graphics might not
sound like an
algorithmic discipline,
I'll try to convince you
guys that, in some sense,
you could take just about
anybody in our department,
have them teach 6.006, and
give a similar talk that,
like, the material that you've
encountered in this course
is going to be
relevant to your life.
The other course that I teach
that might be of interest--
and actually, is a little
more theoretically flavored--
that I teach is 6.838.
So since Erik so kindly put
my name on the board here,
I guess I can draw
The So the main object
of interest in 6.838
is a particular thing
called the simplicial complex.
Usually, in 6.006,
we spend a lot
of time thinking about graphs.
Let me draw you a graph.
So I'm going to take a
square and subdivide it.
And now, let's say I put
edges diagonally like that.
Now, in 6.006, this
thing is just a bunch
of nodes connected by edges.
In fact, if I took this edge and
I moved it down or something,
it would be the same graph.
But of course, in a lot of
computer graphics applications,
this thing also looks an
awful lot like a square.
And the reason is
that, of course,
the graph here contains
triangles inside of it.
And so for instance,
maybe I think of my graph
as a collection of vertices,
a collection of edges.
This is the sort of
notation we've seen before.
And then I add a third
thing to my description,
which is a set of triplets.
That's a set of triangles here.
And we can take a
lot of the algorithms
that we've talked
about in this class
and extend it to this case.
For example, here's a
deceptively annoying one.
Let's say that I want the
shortest path between two
vertices of my graph.
We certainly have learned
Dijkstra's algorithm.
That's one technique to do that.
And indeed, common practice
in computer graphics,
which is shameful, is
on your triangle mesh,
if you want the shortest path
between two vertices, run
Dijkstra's algorithm
on the edges.
And let's see if that
works really quick.
Let's say that I want the
shortest path between--
and, by the way, I'm going to
assume the length of my edges
are the lengths as I've
drawn them on the board here.
So it's like 1, 1,
square root of 2.
OK.
So let's say I want the shortest
path between the bottom left
and the upper right.
If I run Dijkstra's algorithm,
we're in good shape, right?
We get-- I'll let you do
the computations at home.
You'll get the path
that is these two edges.
But here's a really
annoying thing.
Let's say, instead, I
wanted the shortest path
from the upper left
to the lower right.
If I run Dijkstra's algorithm
on this triangulated square,
what's going to be
the shortest path?
Yeah.
In fact, there's
a bunch of them.
One of them might go all
the way down, and then
all the way to the right.
What's the length of this path?
1, 2, 3, 4.
Is that the length
of the shortest path?
Well, probably not.
Well, we would like our shortest
path to do something like that.
But graphs don't know
how to talk to triangles.
And this is going
to be a problem.
In fact, it wasn't until
fairly recently [INAUDIBLE]
history terms that we were
able to kind of work out
the correct algorithm
for the shortest
path in a triangulated
domain like this.
And that's the runtime
that we would expect.
This is called MMP.
I'm guessing Erik and
Jason could do a better
job describing it than I can.
But the basic idea
of the MMP algorithm
actually is a really--
happens to be a nice
extension of the way
that we taught Dijkstra's
algorithm in 6.006,
because they really do
keep track of these level
sets of the distance function.
But now, the level
sets have to--
oops-- have to window
and edge like that
when I compute shortest path,
which is a giant headache.
This is one of these
algorithms that
was known in theory about 10
years before anybody bothered
to implement it in a way that
they could convince themselves
it ran in n log n time.
And nowadays, there's a cottage
industry in computer graphics
research papers to
implement this and then
speed it up in different ways.
And sadly, the reality is that
a different algorithm that we
cover in 6.838 called
fast marching--
which doesn't actually
give you the shortest path,
but some approximation thereof--
is faster, easier to use, and
basically indistinguishable.
In any event, in
6.838, we kind of
have an interesting
dual-mindset.
We'll talk about a
lot of algorithms
that look like what we've done
in whatever this class is--
6.006.
But at the same time, start to
have a more geometric flavor,
and we don't worry quite
as much about [INAUDIBLE]..
So in our computation
model, oftentimes, we're
kind of OK with real
numbers, because that's not
where the headache is.
And of course, when you
write code in this class,
you use double-precision
floating-point.
If you're more responsible, like
in Jason's previous lecture,
you should probably keep track
of the number of operations
to make sure that
your error is counted.
But I'm not sure that we
really bother with that.
In any event, this allows us
to have two different mindsets.
There's one mindset,
which is discrete.
There's another mindset,
which is smooth.
We think about understanding
geometry, like these triangular
domains, as an approximation
of a smooth surface.
And then we might want to do
stuff like compute curvature
and so on, which is really
associated with computing
derivatives, which
of course, we'll
have on these kinds
of simplicial objects.
And that leads to this really
fun area of math and computer
science, whatever, called
discrete differential
geometry, which sounds like
a contradiction in terms.
And it's something that we
covered in quite some detail
in this course.
So we build up, all of calculus,
that the only calculations
you're left to do
are on the vertices
and edges and triangles
of a triangle mesh.
And get pretty far, including
some constructions of topology,
like the Duran
complex, and so on.
I would argue, actually, if
you take our course and then
the differential
geometry courses
in that department,
somehow, some of the indices
and headaches that you often
encounter in that world
are much more
concrete when you try
to make them work on a mesh.
In any event, I think I've
already spent all of my time.
I can tell you a little bit
about research in our group.
I really lead kind of a weird,
extremely [INAUDIBLE] group,
where some of our students are
essentially theory students--
touch your keyboard.
I'm sorry.
It was a reflex.
But it was fast.
All right.
So we have some students
whose background
is in math, other
ones that we're
in autonomous driving
industry and decided
to come back and
work in research.
Because of that, we have
this extremely broad set
of research problems,
everything from the sort
of classic machine learning
problems you might encounter
in geometry world-- like if
I have a self-driving car
and I want to identify
pedestrians and other cars
on the road in an efficient
and accurate fashion.
By the way, part of
that is machine learning
and deep whatever, but
there's another part,
which is algorithms.
Because actually, what comes
into your LiDAR scanner
is on the order of
[INAUDIBLE] with points
and some minuscule
fraction of time.
And time complexity of
your learning algorithm
actually is really
critical to get it right,
and something that there are a
lot of open problems right now,
because it's really not
compatible with the hardware
architecture that
these cars often use.
We also look at [INAUDIBLE]
geometry problems,
like if I give you data, can
I find a geometric structure?
So it's a classic example of
natural language processing.
When we use words like near
and far, in terms of semantics
and meaning, all the time.
The question is, can we actually
find an embedded of our word
data into a geometric
space to facilitate
the statistical algorithms
that we care about?
And of course, we apply geometry
to lots of practical problems,
everything from meshing
and scientific computing,
which I think is sort
of a classic one--
in fact, I think we're the first
group that sort of enumerated
all of the cool things that may
happen to decahedral meshes,
which is this
bottom figure here.
I should show this to people.
There's some fun things
to look at there.
To other practical
problems, like taking--
Erik took a zebra and folded it.
We can take a zebra and move its
texture onto a cat or a pig--
or, actually, off the
side of the screen.
But if we don't move the paper,
[INAUDIBLE] for the 3D scan
of what it might [INAUDIBLE].
In any event, in my five
minutes remaining here,
I thought I would dig into a
little bit of detail of two--
or maybe one application,
depending on when
Jason and Erik get bored.
And essentially, my
message for you guys
is, of course, [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not really a
central CS theory group
member here at MIT.
But unfortunately for you
guys, 6.006 is unavoidable.
Even if you want to go into
deep learning, statistics,
whatever-- data science--
you're going to encounter
the material that you've
seen in this course.
And in fact, it's really
the bread and butter
of just about everything
everybody does here
in this Data Center.
So then, I'll give you two
quick examples, one of which
lifted from my teaching,
one from my research.
If you continue
with me next fall,
we'll teach 6.837, which is
the Intro to Computer Graphics
course.
One thing that's always
amazing to students
is, these, algorithms
that produce
these really beautiful
images, can fit in about 10,
20 lines of code.
So really, this is
totally facetious,
because if you want
those beautiful images
and you use those
20 lines of code,
you'll be waiting until
the death of the universe
to actually compute
these things.
But in any event, one nice
one for rendering-- so
drawing a bunch of
shapes [INAUDIBLE],,
something called ray casting,
or its better known cousin,
ray tracing.
Typically, the difference
is whether your rays
can bounce off of the surface
and have a secondary thing.
Right.
Here's the ray
casting algorithm.
Let's say I have a scene built
out of spheres and cubes.
I'm going to have a for
loop over every pixel
on the computer screen.
For every pixel,
I've got to discover
what color that should be.
So I shoot a ray from my
eyeball through that pixel
and find the first
object that it runs into.
It's not so hard to
intersect a line of a sphere
or a line of a cube.
So what is that algorithm?
I've given it to you
on the screen here.
Not too bad to think about.
And I think you guys
are all extremely well
equipped to analyze
the runtime of this,
which is roughly
the number of pixels
times the number of objects.
Because for every
pixel, I've got
to decide what object the ray
out of my eyeball hits first.
So I need a for loop
over [INAUDIBLE]..
Make sense?
Cool.
So let's look at a
basic rendering problem.
In fact, Erik already secretly
snuck this one in here.
There's a very famous 3D model
called the Stanford bunny.
The Stanford bunny is
actually a great example
of a simplicial complex--
in fact, a manifold one,
triangulated surface.
Actually, I'm not sure it's
manifold in its original form.
But usually, it is.
And this innocent-looking,
extremely famous 3D model
is actually quite pernicious.
It's composed of
69,000 triangles.
And if I wanted
1080p-- like a high def
rendering of my triangle--
then, of course,
there's two million
pixels on the screen.
So if we look at our
big O expression,
roughly, our
computation time scales
like the product of
those two big numbers.
So just to render
this ugly gray bunny
takes me a pretty
large amount of time.
And in fact, the reality--
by the way, the bunny
is this famous test case
in computer graphics,
so if you take my class, you'll
be rendering buddies all day.
The reality is,
we don't want just
grayed, flat-shaded bunnies.
We want bunnies that are
transparent, and reflecting
stuff, and I shoot my
bunny with a bullet
and shatters into a
million pieces, and all
of these cool things.
So of course that,
ray casting algorithm,
with each one of these new
graphics features I add,
only adds to the time
complexity of the technique
that I implement.
So pretty quickly-- and indeed,
if you write your own ray
tracer at home, which I
strongly encourage you to do--
what you will discover
is that a [INAUDIBLE]
would be the technical phrase.
What is our way out of this?
Well, if you take
it 837, you'll see
that our way out
of these problems,
in graphics, is data
structures and algorithms.
It's completely unavoidable.
For instance, obviously, we
spent quite a bit of time
in this course talking
about AVL trees.
In 837, we'll spend a big
chunk of our tours talking
about space partitioning trees.
Here-- I actually forgot
what kind of tree this is.
I think it's a KD tree.
Doesn't matter.
In any event, one
thing I could do
is take all of the
triangles of my bunny,
and I could put the entire
bunny in a giant cube
with the property that the
cube is outside the bunny.
Let's say I cast a ray and the
ray doesn't touch the cube.
Can the ray touch the bunny?
No, right?
It zings right past it.
So suddenly, I just saved myself
a lot of computation time,
right?
I don't have to iterate over
all the triangles inside
of the body to see whether
they hit the ray or not,
because I already
convinced myself,
by this conservative
test, that I
didn't hit even the bounding
box of the whole bunny.
Well, that's sort of a
nice order 1 speed-up.
But depending on
how big the bunny
is relative to the size
of my rendered image,
that might not be a super
useful efficiency test.
But of course, what could I do?
I could take the box
containing the bunny,
I could slice it in half,
and now it's saying,
does my ray hit the front
or the back of the bunny?
Or maybe both.
That's where you've got to--
that's where things get gnarly.
And so on.
So now you have this nice
recursive tree structure,
where I keep taking the
box containing my bunny
and chopping it in
half and placing--
in some sense, usually,
the triangles--
maybe not the leaves of my
tree, but [INAUDIBLE] that's
probably good enough.
You get a structure like what
you see on the screen here.
And why should you do that?
Well, remember, it takes pn time
to render my image of my bunny
normally.
Well, now, the
picture is actually
misleadingly suggestive.
But you might think that,
maybe, it takes roughly--
remember, n is the number
of objects in my scene--
p log n time to
render my bunny now,
because I can kind of
traverse the tree of objects
in my scene.
Of course, notice, I put
a question mark here.
And the devil's in
the details here.
In fact, I think computer
graphics people often
believe that their rendering
algorithm takes p log n time.
That's often not
possible, although kind
of an interesting
question, which
is, the heuristics they use for
building these sorts of trees
often do, on average,
give them log n time.
And so there's
something about the data
that's making this problem
easier than it might seem.
So we'll dig into that a little
bit in the graphics class.
Of course, you're not going
to proof as many bounds
as you might in a theory course.
But we're certainly
building on the intuition
that we've seen in this class
to build on practical data
structures.
And these data structures
appear everywhere
in computer graphics.
For instance, directed
acyclic graphs
appear all over the place in
computer graphics literature
to describe 3D scenes.
For example, this classroom
is a stark reminder
of why we need DAGs
and computer graphics,
because we have all of
these empty seats here,
and they're all
copies of one another.
So would it make sense for
me to store however many,
like, 100 3D molds
of the same chair?
Probably not.
So instead, what do I do?
I store one instance of a chair,
and then some instructions
on how to tile it
into my entire scene.
One way that I can
do that is to think
of there being a
node in a graph which
knows how to draw one chair.
And now, I can have a
bunch of different nodes
in my scene for all of
the instances of the chair
and then store a different
transformation for each one.
So if you think about
the graph structure here,
each of those ones is going to
point into the same 3D model
of the chair for rendering.
And that makes a directed
acyclic graph structure
called a scene graph, which
we'll spend quite a bit of time
talking about in 837, how
to traverse and construct
all that good stuff.
And there are lots of
different models of computation
in that universe, as well.
Your graphics card is
a very specific kind
of parallel processor
that's kind of like Lucille
Ball on the conveyor belt,
hammering at the same object
over and over again.
But if you ask it to do
anything other than the one
thing it knows how to do to
a bunch of data at a time,
then all of your computation
grinds to a halt.
This is called Single
Instruction Multiple Data
parallelism, SIMD.
Numerical algorithms
matter a lot
for things like
fluid simulation.
And approximation algorithms
are quite critical, too.
In computer graphics,
the complexity
is kind of interesting,
because of course, your eyeball
is sensitive to
about 29.97 frames
per second worth of material.
You can choose that time to
do really well-rendering one
object, but then you take out
of the time rendering something
else.
There's kind of an
interesting conservation law
that you have to
balance when you solve
these kinds of problems, which
is an interesting balance, now,
between complexity and
runtime of your algorithm
and perception.
What things can you get away
with when you draw a scene?
And maybe I can do tons
of extra computation
to get that extra shadow,
but it's just not worth it.
I'll quickly sketch out
another completely different
application of the
material that we've covered
in 6.006 from my own research.
Again, just like Erik--
I guess, in a funny way,
both of our groups, I think,
are kind of broad in terms of
subject material, rather than--
some of our colleagues
have really laser focus
on one topic or another.
Another Research area that
I have sort of backed into
is the area of
political redistricting.
This is relevant in
the United States.
Recently, I've been
reading this great proposal
about other countries, which
is really interesting, how
they do this stuff.
In the US, when we vote
for people in Congress--
by the way, not
necessarily for presidents.
This is a common misconception.
But certainly for
Congress, your state
is divided into little
regions, each of which
elects one member of the House.
And there's sort of a
subtle problem if you're not
used to thinking
about it, or one
that's staring you in the
face and screaming, depending
on how often you read
the news and politics.
There is an issue
called gerrymandering,
where your legislature draws the
lines for what area on the map
elects a member of Congress.
And depending on how
you draw the lines,
you can engineer
different results
for who's likely to get elected.
So for instance, maybe
there's some minority.
I can cluster them all together
into one voting district.
Then they will only
get the opportunity
to elect one person.
But maybe, if I divide the
space where they live into two,
I managed to engineer
two districts
with a high probability
of electing somebody
with their political
interests in mind.
It turns out that
political redistricting,
in a broad sense, is a great
problem, computationally.
Even if you're a totally
heartless theorist,
there are some really
fun problems here.
So for example,
the state of Iowa--
we all pick on Iowa because
it has a unique law, which
is that districts have to be
built out of counties, which
are much larger than
the typical census unit,
so it computationally is easier.
But even in Iowa,
which is a giant grid--
with the exception of one
shift in the middle, which
is fascinating to me--
I know [INAUDIBLE], fun fact.
Literally, people were
making the map of Iowa,
and they worked from the
bottom up and the top down,
and it meets in the middle
and their grids were shifted,
and now we're stuck with that.
And it has an interesting effect
on the topology of the graph,
because it looks like
squares, but then there's
triangles in the middle.
But in any event,
even though there's
only 99 counties
in four districts,
there's approximately
quintillions of possible ways
you can divide that state into
four contiguous districts that
satisfy the rules as they were--
at least, if you read the
code literally in the law.
It seems like
computers are useful,
but unfortunately, it's
a little subtle how.
For instance, there's no
single "best" districting
plan out there.
I can't think of a single
state with a law that gives you
an objective function, similar
to whatever cute characters
that we've had in 6.006.
They often have very
clear objectives in life,
but unfortunately,
redistricting, that's
very rarely the case.
You have to balance
contiguity, population balance,
compactness, all of
these different things.
Reality check number two
is that, even if somebody
did give you an
objective function,
for just about any interesting
it's very obvious that
generating the best possible
districting plan is NP-hard.
And by the way, it
doesn't even matter,
because the law doesn't
say that computers have
to draw the best districts.
Even if P equals NP
really could extract
the best possible districting
plan using an algorithm,
it doesn't mean you have
to use it, at least the way
the law's written now.
Interestingly, this is not true
in certain parts of Mexico,
where they actually make
you compare your districting
plan against a
computer-generated one, which
is philosophically
really interesting,
although in practice, it
doesn't work terribly well.
Our researchers studied analysis
of districting plans instead.
So instead of running a
piece of software that
takes in your state,
draws your districts,
and then you're done--
instead, we ask
statistical questions
about, I propose a
districting plan,
what does it look like
relative to the space
of the possibilities?
So that, of course,
begs the question,
what are the possibilities?
So these are the connected
graph partitions.
Meaning, you have a graph,
and you take the vertices
and you cluster them together
in a way where they're
connected to one another.
The one thing that we all agree
on-- actually, philosophically,
it's questionable why--
is that you should
be able to start
at any point in your district
and walk to any other one
without leaving.
These days, with
the internet, it's
not clear that that's
actually the best criterion.
But that's a law that,
I think, is never
going to get passed
in the near future.
Anyway, I think I'm
out of time, so I
don't think I'll walk you
guys through the theory here.
Maybe I'll leave
it in the slides.
There's a sort of
very simple proof
that can show that, at least the
very simplest thing you might
think of for analyzing
your districting plan,
which is to say,
you propose a plan,
and now, I want your
plan to be at least as
good, under some axis, as
it's a randomly drawn one
from the space of all possible
connected partitions--
all of the possible ways
I could draw the lines.
Well, then, it might
be useful to have
a piece of software that
could just randomly draw
such a thing.
So in other words,
to draw something
where the probability
of any one partition
is 1 over the number
of partitions.
This seems innocent.
In fact, there's a
number of papers that
claim to do things like this.
But it turns out that it's
computationally difficult,
assuming that you believe
that P doesn't equal NP.
So I'll maybe leave
some suggestive pictures
in the slide that we can--
if you guys text me, or if we
have a professor-student chat,
I'm happy to sketch
it out to you then.
There's a very nice,
easy proof that
reduces this to
Hamiltonian cycle,
and shows you that maybe you
shouldn't trust these tools,
as much as they're
argued about, literally,
in the Supreme Court a
couple of months ago.
By the way, it was pretty fun.
Our expert report was referenced
in the defense of the case
last summer.
And when you read
the discussion,
you can see the
judges trying to talk
their way around complexity.
And it's an interesting,
if somewhat dry, read.
In any event, that's
just the starting point
for our research, which
says that, of course,
these sampling problems
are really hard.
The questions is,
what can you do?
[INAUDIBLE] or not.
But the real message
here is, of course,
that this course is unavoidable.
Even in these extremely
applied problems
showing up in court cases or on
your graphics card, you still--
complexity and algorithms
and data structures
are going to come back to play.
So with that, our
other two instructors
up here for our final farewell--
suitably distance ourselves.
ERIK DEMAINE: So
algorithms are everywhere.
I hope you enjoyed this class.
It's been a lot of fun teaching
you and having you as students.
Even though you're not here
physically in the room,
we still feel your presence.
And I look forward to
seeing you all soon.
Thanks for being a
part of this fun thing.
I want to thank our two--
my two co-instructors for an
awesome time this semester.
It's been a lot of fun
teaching to you guys.
JASON KU: Thanks for spending
006 with us this term.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yeah.
Thank you.
And hopefully we'll
see you again soon.
ERIK DEMAINE: Bye.
JASON KU: Bye.